daniel legault qui a fait les beaux
jours de l'équipe de france de voile en
martinique
ce technicien expérimenté entre autres
eu des compétiteurs à la recherche d'une
meilleure place possible
ce un plateau où le vin se fait souvent
des îles et ça se joue sur la sur
l'ambition sur la motivation de
d'arriver à devenir un athlète de haut
niveau donc dès maintenant à partir sur
de bonnes bases sur de bonnes bases de
préparation physique de préparation
tactique stratégique d'analystes du plan
d'eau de tous les paramètres de la voile
pour arriver au plus haut niveau pendant
tout au long de leur future carrière
la préparation des quatre jours de
rigueur a commencé à schoelcher quelle
que soit la série plus de cent soixante
dix compétiteurs attendus
les organisateurs annoncent une
compétition relevée avec des délégations
venues de la caraïbe d'europe et de la
bd nord cette semaine nautique ont fait
permet d'avoir du niveau pour les
compétiteurs de la zone antilles guyane
on va dire puisqu'on à toute l'équipe de
la voix de prix présente saint
barthélémy et permet de se confronter
aux meilleurs nationaux il ya aussi les
canadiens qui viennent passer chez super
faire naviguer en face à ce moment
compte tenu des conditions météo c'est
plus facile de naviguer ici donc c'est
thomas nautique permet à aux
compétiteurs locaux de se confronter à
plus fort quant à naviguer ici on peut
naviguer en fait d'autres adro monde
parce que le vent irrégulier on doit
tout le temps être vigilent a regardé
tout l'organisation les bonnes et puis
les conditions voilà d'accueil et tout
sort très bien aussi
voilà pourquoi pour qu'on vient ici
cette semaine internationale de
chercheurs permettra aux martiniquais de
se situer la dialyse avait connu des
fortunes diverses
devant des techniciens de renault